hello oh hello am i speaking with
Francis Arnold you are hi hi I'm Adam
Smith from nobelprize.org
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize thank you
you sound very calm and collected in the
middle of the night in Texas I'm not the
least I'm bouncing off the walls but I'm
trying to pretend to sound calm and
collected I imagine you're away from
home so perhaps somewhat protected from
the immediate onslaught that's going to
happen today
well I'm annoyed because I can't reach
my son you started as a mechanical
engineer and now I suppose you're a
protein engineer do you think that is
part of the secret of your success that
you came from a different field into
biology and were able to see things
differently I think there's no doubt
about that
I was able to look at the problem with a
totally fresh set of eyes a problem that
had challenged people since the
techniques were upside directed
mutagenesis for example which won the
Nobel Prize were were available and I
realized that that the way that most
people were going about protein
engineering was doomed to failure it's a
bold move Oh to jump field so radically
oh I have four brothers and I've jumped
into all sorts of things over my life so
learning new things has always been fun
for me changing fields has been fun and
I still feel that way many years later
would it be fair to say that what you do
is to sort of manipulate nature's
inventiveness for human benefit what I
think of what I do is
copying nature's design process right
here all this tremendous beauty and
complexity of the biological world all
comes about through this one simple
beautiful design algorithm and what I do
is use that algorithm to build new
biological things and it's it's not it's
obvious it's totally obvious that this
is the way it should be done can you
give me an example of one of your
favorite things that you've been able to
evolve well what I work on now is
someone asked me what's the funnest
thing or what's the best thing that you
you've ever done it's always what I'm
doing now so what I'm doing now is
looking at this question of how do you
evolve innovation how does innovation
happen how do you get a whole new
chemical reactivity that you don't know
already existed nature how can i evolve
a whole new species and in in essence a
whole new species of enzyme and so for
example making a carbon silicon bond
humans thought only they could do it but
we've all been in front of it does it
better than humans do I'm not I said
absolutely I suppose nature's doing this
all the time that it's coming up with
new enzymes itself of course she is
nature is solving all sorts of problems
that we throw at her how did the grey
plastic bottles how did the great
pesticides and herbicides and
antibiotics she creates new enzymes in
response to that all the time in real
time I suppose that should have a the
fears of people who say that humans
shouldn't be tinkering with nature well
nature's tinkering with itself so it's
not so different really is it well we've
been tinkering with nature for tens of
thousands of years look at a poodle we
created all sorts of organisms and
biological things that wouldn't be here
were it not for us
hmm it's true and poodles haven't done
much damage to us so far that's right
and they solve all sorts of problems
look at it look at the bite the
Agricultural Revolution and food look at
look at their farm animals look at our
pet
these are human creation humanity needs
science to get over the hurdles ahead
that is really true we need science and
we need the smartest minds to work on
these problems you are already a member
of all three national academies of
Sciences in the u.s. you have multiple
awards what do you think the Nobel Prize
will mean to you I don't know yet I
haven't had it very long let me rephrase
the question
what does it mean to you at this moment
at this moment I'm absolutely thrilled
and I can't wait to get home and tell my
son really couldn't be a better answer
Fanta fantastic
well we very much look forward to seeing
you in Stockholm in December and thank
you very much for talking to me
thank you Adam bye bye